I apologize the Secretary Clinton and I
hope we can work together on an
independent investigation from day one I
want to apologize to my supporters this
is not the type of campaign that we run
Secretary Clinton he's apologized how do
you react I think you know we've
resolved your data we've agreed on a
independent inquiry we should move on
because I don't think the American
people are all that interested in this
you want to know why things don't get
done in Washington because for the last
24 hours with those issues being so
urgent to people as they tune in tonight
wondering how they're going to even be
able to buy presents for their kids
instead we're listening to the bickering
back and forth me